Okay. So today we will do Emanuel Kant
and Frederick Hegel. So um my main
argument is that Kant is really taking
the main thesis of Dante
um which is the imagination is the
animating force of the universe and love
is the unifying force of the universe.
And and what he will do is he will use
his
epistomology. Epismology just means
theory of knowledge. How do we know what
we know? And he will you and then he
will uh do three things. He will clarify
it. Okay. So if you read Dante, it's not
very explicit what he's saying. You have
to interpret him properly. What Kant
will do is make Dante explicit to the
world. Then he will rationalize it.
rationalize it just means that he will
remove divinity. He will remove theology
from it and create um a system of logic.
Okay? And so then he will systemize
it. All right? So this is the mission of
Kant to take the secret of the universe
as first presented in Dante and then
create a system of logic that then is
able to incorporate itself
into science and history and philosophy
and the world that we know. All right.
So together Dante and Khan really did
create the world that we live in today.
All right. So um let's first talk about
the background like why is Kant engaged
in this project. Um so for most of
western history there have been two
major philosophers. They are um
Plato and
Aristotle. And up until the point and up
until Kant you could divide all
philosophy into these two major camps.
Um Plato ha believes that God is called
the form of the
good. Form of the good. So the form of
the good it is this perfect immaculate
eternal force that emits emanates
breathes thinks and then he creates
something called the ideals. And these
are the per perfection perfect
conceptions of beauty, reason, justice.
And then these ideals give rise to the
forms. Okay. And these are the perfect
encapsulation of these ideals. So think
of the perfect horse or the perfect
chair or the perfect square. Okay.
Um we live this is the real world. Okay.
This is what is true and real. We live
in the shadow world. So remember back to
the allegory of the cave. So everything
in the shadow world is only a
imitation of the
forms. And so um in this conception what
is good is to move towards the form of
the good to return to the form of the
good and what is evil is to move away
from the form of the good. Okay. That's
why for Plato art poetry is evil because
you're imitating imitation. And what
then why for Plato
mathematics and philosophy are
inherently good uh because it is
teaching you how to return to the form
of the good and Plato's important
because what happens is that Plato's
ideas become the basis for
heaven and earth. Right? And so this is
the basis for Christianity.
Remember in the Catholic Church doctrine
um your life our life on this planet
doesn't really matter. What matters is
our return to heaven to be with God. Um
and we say about Plato that he's very
that he's a dualist. Okay. So there are
three conceptions of the universe. There
is the materialistic worldview which is
what Aristotle is. Materialistic just
says that only things that you can see
and touch matter. Um idealistic is what
Hegel will represent which is that only
ideas matter. And then Plato believes
that both um matter and ideas do matter.
Okay. So he's a dualist whereas
Aristotle is a materialist. All right.
So that's Plato. Uh pretty clear, right?
Good. All right. Now let's move on to
Aristotle. For Aristotle, his god is
called a prime mover. The prime mover is
the first thing that moves because when
the first thing moves it causes um
things to move as well. Okay, there's
cause and
effect. So in this world what matters is
movement. Okay, everything's moving
towards what towards something called
tilos which is what purpose is. It's
it's a Greek word for purpose. So for
example as a teacher my tilos is to
teach as well as I can and my mission in
life is to constantly learn to improve
and to practice so that my teacher
becomes better and better okay that's
the idea of tilos and we can understand
through
observation and
experience what each things's tilos is
and then you can start to categorize
things okay and um Aristotle his ideas
of course become the bas basis for
science. Okay. And I and as I mentioned,
Aristotle has a materialistic worldview
as opposed to Plato's dualistic
worldview. Aristotle doesn't really care
about things outside the material world.
He's only concerned about the here and
now. So these are the two major major
school of thought um during integrity.
Now um as I mentioned previously in
class as a cath as a Catholic church um
comes into power and and it has a
monopoly power it suppresses these
philosophical um inquiries. Okay. Um but
after the renaissance uh these schools
of thought Plato and Aristotle they will
reemerge. All right. So um they will
reemerge into three major schools of
thought. Okay. So um taking up
Plato's perspective
uh will be a people called the
rationalist. Okay. So the three most
famous rationalists are Rene Deart uh
Lemnix and Spinosa. Okay. But they are
basically adopting Plato's worldview
which is there is a god and through
mathematics through logic we can from
first principles
um reason out the mind of god. All
right. So the project of rationalism is
towards
omniscience and again this is best
represented by um
deart and this becomes of course the
basis for the enlightenment right so
that's the first major school of thought
the rationalists um they're also called
the continentals the continental
uh philosophy because it's really based
on the continent of Europe um opposing
the rationalists are the empiricis
Okay. And these are people who are
adopting the
Aristotle worldview. Uh the emperorist,
the most famous is John Lock. And what
John Lock believes is our minds are born
tabula
rasa which just means blank slate
meaning there's nothing in our minds. So
the only way that we can acquire
knowledge, acquire wisdom is through
experience.
Okay, experience and something called
induction. So in logic there are two
um meth methods. The first is deduction
where you take the generalize to the
specific and then induction is to take
the specific and then you generalize it
into the abstract. Okay. So for example,
if I see five boys wearing white shirts,
then I can generalize and say that all
boys wear uh white shirts. But if the
general principle is all boys wear white
shirt, then reduction I can say, well
you're a boy, therefore you wear a white
shirt. Okay, so that's the idea of
empiricism. And of course this becomes
the basis for what we call the
scientific
method, right?
Now, there's another school of
philosophy called skepticism. And this
was pioneered mainly by a man named
David Hume. And so, what David Hume is
going to do is he's going to look at
this idea of induction and argue, no,
you can't do that. You cannot generalize
things. Just because you meet 1 million
swan that are white does not mean that
all swan are white. It is entirely
possible that there's a black swan out
there. Okay. So, um what David Hume does
is he negates induction. And what he
argues
is basically our understanding of the
world is based primarily on custom. For
him, custom just means consensus. We
agree this is right. Therefore, it is
right. There's no inherent truth to this
thing. All right. So um David Hume is
very controversial because he argues
that knowledge true knowledge is just
impossible which means that the inver
the entire project of philosophy is
pointless. Okay you know what you know
through experience and through custom
you cannot abstract things. You cannot
reason out things beyond that and
therefore what's the point of
philosophy. All right so that's uh David
Hume. Now um what's going to happen is
Emanuel Khan is going to read David Hume
and be so agonized over his conclusions
that he writes something called the
critique of pure reason. Okay. And this
is considered the greatest treatise of
philosophy ever in human history. It's
extremely dense, extremely complicated.
Um and quite honestly I have not been
able to complete it. Okay, I've tried my
best but it is way too difficult uh for
me. So what I'm going to do today is I'm
I'm going to
oversimplify his argument in order to
make it clear for us. Okay? He's so
fundamental to development of human
civilization that we need to study him.
But I'm warning you that I am not in any
way an expert on Kant. But I hope that
today's class will become a basis for
your further study and inquiry into uh
Kant and philosophy. Okay. All right. So
in his critique critique of pure reason
what K's going to do is he's going to
show that all three schools of thought
rationalism empiricism and skeptism are
all in their own way problematic and and
in doing so he's going to construct a
new theory of everything a new theory of
the world that will become the
cornerstone for neuroscience
um physics and um artificial
intelligence. Okay. So his contribution
to humani civilization cannot be
understated. All right. So for Kant this
rational school is problematic because
he believes that omniscience is just not
possible. It is impossible for us to
ever achieve the mind of God. There are
limitations to the pursuit of knowledge.
There are limitations to our capacity to
reason. Okay. So that's the first uh
argument. Second argument
is the empiricist argument of tabular
rasa cannot possibly be true. He's going
to show us through a lot of empirical
proof that there's it's not just it's
not possible for minds to be blank
slates. We need to have certain
mechanisms of thought already in place
for us to uh engage with the world.
Okay. So that's the problem with
um um the empiricist. His problem with
Hume is he believes that there's
knowledge that is real and inherent and
true and it's and so knowledge can be
pursued. Philosophy is important. In
fact, for Khan, philosophy is the most
important pursuit in human history.
Okay. So, um by responding to all three
of these major schools, Khan in his
critic of pure reason, he's going to
create a radical new theory of the
world. Okay? his own uh unique
epestmology based on the thinking of
Dante. All right. So let's go into his
argument very quickly and again this is
an
oversimplification. All right. So
um we are all endowed with the capacity
to reason. Okay. We all have minds and
our minds engage reality. Okay. What
Kant says is this. The moment that we
engage in
reality, we create a new uh universe
called
parents. Okay. So, um let me first go
over the the terminology. It's very
important you understand terminology in
order to understand uh Kant. Okay.
So um for
Kant reality are
things in
themselves and here you he uses the
Greek uh
nomina. Okay, things in
themselves. This is the world that is
true and real. And then the word of
appearance are what I call things for
us. things that we see but which may not
be true. And he uses the Greek word
phenomena. Okay. And what he's arguing
is within us there is a mechanism in our
minds that is
always perceiving reality in a way that
allows us to understand, interpret and
manipulate it. Okay. Okay. So this is
his thesis. Okay. So um let me first
explain how he got to this thesis. So
what Khan does is this. He reasons
out he tries to reason out what is
possible in espanology. Okay philosophy.
And so what he does is he creates
categories. So uh there are four major
categories that we need to know. Okay.
And again this is a bit technical and
complicated but we need to do this in
order to fully understand Kant. So what
Kant says is there are two types of um
knowledge. There's a
priority and there's a
proster. Okay. Um apriori is Latin for
things that come before. Uh apostro is
Latin for things that come after. All
right. So aporei means knowledge that is
independent of experience things that
are universal and necessary things that
are true in themselves and a story of
course are things that uh you learn
after you experience it. Okay. Uh he
also has two more categories of logic.
The first is called the
analytical. The analytical and then the
second is called the synthetic.
Okay, analytical just
means things that are true in
themselves. So they are true by
definition. So if I say for example, a
square has four sides. A triangle has
three sides. That's an analytical
statement because it's true in itself.
Okay, I can also say that A is a. I can
also say that Mary is a woman. Okay,
these are all just identity statements,
things that are true in themselves.
synthetics. And so synthetic statements
are statements that are not analytical,
meaning that you need to
um build these statements based on um
other information and they could be
false. Okay? So just think think of
synthetic as
non-analytical. So um what Kant does
then is says well then then if there are
two by two there's four possibilities.
Okay. And if you think about what apore
analytical is, that's just what logic
is, right? This is just what's logical.
Apore story synthetic is just what we
call empirical. This is the John Lock
project, right? Empiricism things that
you know and learn after you experience
it. Um analytical a story is just
doesn't really matter, right? Because a
square has four sides. It doesn't matter
if you see a square, four sides, it
doesn't really change anything. The main
conflict between David Hume and Emil
Kant is whether or not a priority
synthetic knowledge exists. For David
Hume, he says this in in uh his
writings. It is impossible for a
synthetic knowledge to exist. But what
Emanuel K will show us is it does exist
and he calls it transcendental
idealism.
Transcendental idealism. Okay. and he's
going to spend his entire um book a
critic of pure reason about a thousand
pages explaining why this must be true.
Why is it that you must have a priority
synthetic knowledge in your brain in
order to understand the world? All
right. So again this is his main
argument and what it will show us is
this. If you study mathematics, if you
look at philosophy, if you look at uh
classical physics, Newtonian physics and
you break things down to the most
fundamental level, what you will
discover
is we have to bring in certain
assumptions into this field of knowledge
for it to exist. Okay? And these two
very basic um things that we bring in
are called space and time.
Space and time. Okay, space just mean
sensation and time is
sequence. Okay, se time is just an order
things. One, two, three, four, five.
Space is just our interaction with the
world around us. Unless we have two
these two basic concepts, no knowledge
is possible. Right? Space and time. So
this is really important and this is a
hard concept to understand. What Connor
is saying is that space and time do not
exist in reality. Space and time is a
projection of our minds in order to we
can substitize reality in a way that
allows us to understand it and
manipulate it. Okay. Space and
time. All right.
Um in other words, okay, a very simple
way to understand this is our minds turn
the world into a story. Why? Because if
you have space and time, you have
causality, cause and effect. Okay? Spa,
time movement, right? So now you have
causality. Causality is a story. So what
Khan is saying is we are just imagining
reality into a story and that allows us
to understand it. All
right. So um what Kant's going to do
after he proves that space and time must
exist a priority is he's now going to
explain how we take reality and we turn
it into
appearance.
Okay. And what he's going to show us
is that our mind has a process of doing
this. And this process is three stages.
There's
apprehension, there's
reproduction, and then there's
recognition. Okay, so apprehension is
just you're engaging the things in
themselves and through space time, okay,
by inputting space time into things
themselves, you're able to reproduce it
in your brain. you're able to create an
image of it in your your brain and then
what you're going to do in order to
understand it is to filter spacetime
using something he calls
categories. Okay, categories just think
of it as our algorithm. A better word is
heristic. Okay, horistic. Computers use
algorithms, we use horistics, right? And
there are 12 different categories but
there are four major
um categories. Okay. The first is
quantity. How much of thing it is?
Quality. What what are the properties of
this thing? Um
relation is this thing logical or
empirical? And then modality which is
what's what is the strength of the
relation of this thing. Okay. Okay. I
know it's complicated but later on we
will use some examples from real life to
better understand how this works. All
right so and you don't really need to
remember the the categories just
remember that that what K is saying is
inherent in our mind is a heristic an
algorithm that allows us to turn
information into
knowledge. All right and when we do this
what happens is we create a
schema a representation of the world
which allows for understanding the
world. Okay. Okay, so for example, we
see a lot of triangles, but we don't
actually have an image of a triangle in
our head. We only have a concept of a
triangle in our heads. Okay, and this is
true for a lot of things. All right, so
um and then the schema then enter
returns to the categories which allows
us to filter the world even more. Okay,
so it is a feedback loop. So does this
all make sense? Okay, this is Kant's
perception of the world. Again, if you
want to know the proof, uh if you want
to know his logic, then you have to read
the book uh for yourself, uh which will
take you about 10 years, right? Great.
All right. So,
um all this is saying is this is called
reaffirming the Dante believe that the
imagination is the animating force of
the world. Okay. So, without us, reality
cannot be alive. It is our imagination
that makes um reality alive to us. All
right. Now um this is from the critic of
pure reason. He also wrote a book called
the critic of practical reason where he
presents like a theory of morality. All
right. So let's go over it. So for for K
the highest ideal immorality is
something called the
categorical
imperative. And this is separate and
distinct from something called the
hypothetical imperative. The
hypothetical imperative is okay. If you
are a child in a school, what how should
you behave? Okay, this is specific. This
is circumstantial. The categorical is
the absolute. This is how you should
always behave. And for Kant, there are
three major principles that underly all
morality. Okay, so let's go over them
one by one. The first
is um the idea of universal law. So Khan
says imagine that each of your action
will be universalized will be
generalized so that everyone will behave
the way you do. Okay? So for example you
can choose to steal but imagine everyone
stealing. Well what kind of world would
that be? You certainly would not want to
live in that world, right? So behave as
though everyone is watching you and
everyone's going to do what you're going
to do. Okay? be the best possible
example to everyone. All right, so
that's the first principle. Second
principle is see humans each as a me as
an end onto itself and not as a means.
Okay, do not manipulate people, do not
use people, treat people with
respect.
Okay. And the third um is the idea of
um autonomous
will which means like everything you do
must something that you reason out
yourself. You're not coerced into it.
You're not manipulated into doing it.
You're not tricked into do it. It's
something that you sitting by yourself
in a room, you're able to reason it out
independently. Okay. So this is the idea
of the categorical imperative which Kant
believes is what we should all strive to
and what we're all capable of doing
because we're capable of reason okay
we're capable of imagination we're
capable of imagining a moral
world and this is important because this
becomes the basis for what we have today
the United Nations human rights
international law okay that's how
influential Khan has been in development
of human civiliz civilization All right.
So, how can we understand the
categorical imperative? Well, let's go
back to Jeanjac
Rouso. Remember in Jeanjac Rouso he he
proposed the idea of the general will.
The general will is not democracy. Okay?
Democracy is simply you get everyone to
vote. Okay? So, in this room I ask
everyone what should what should we have
for lunch? and then someone proposes
let's have ice cream and everyone raises
his hand and says yeah let's have ice
cream okay that's democracy but for John
Rouso what he argues is the general will
is the best interest of people that you
can derive from just by reaching out
yourself okay so if you were all sit
down by yourself and ask what should we
have for lunch it wouldn't be ice cream
because ice cream makes you uh fat um
it's too much sugar it's bad for you
okay you would probably think we should
have salad so the general will
represents the best interests of
everyone
involved. Okay? So if I would ask you
what should we have for lunch, everyone
would say if if we are following a
general will um a salad or maybe a
chicken breast or Okay. So in other
words, the kind imperative it is just
the
individualized general will. All right?
It is a general
will that you uh internalize to yourself
and you behave as though you are the
general will. Right? So that's a way of
understanding um the categorical
imperative. Now there's another way of
understanding the categorical imperative
and just using Dante. So remember we
read the divine colony and Dante's
categorical imperative is very simple.
Love someone. Okay? Doesn't matter who
could be your wife. It could be your
mother and it could or it could be your
child. It could be your best friend. But
love that person and when you love that
person then all three thing all three
things are true. It means you are now
going to be your best. It means you are
treating this person with respect. It
means that you're choosing to love this
person. Okay. So
um love is the unifying
force of the universe. All right. So
that's what Dante is really saying. And
so in other words, Kant, he is just
systemizing what Dante said, Divine
Comedy. All right, does that make sense?
All right. So, um, for us to better
understand D, uh, Kant's argument, I
want to give you three examples to
better understand what Kant is saying.
All right, the first example is imagine
you are writing a diary. All right, I
want you to write a diary for a whole
year. So every day you're writing what
happened today. All right, so you have
separate entries. Okay? Right? So every
day um at night at 9:00 p.m. you're just
reflecting on what happened today. And
then at the end of the year, what I want
you to do is write one long diary entry.
Okay? Now, if you think about it, in
theory, these separate entries should
add up to equal this one long entry,
right? But what you'll find actually do
this experiment is this long entry that
you wrote almost has no relation at all
with these 365 separate entries. Does
that make
sense? Right. Okay. So in other words,
what we're doing is constantly every day
we are reimagining the world in a new
way and we're building on top of this.
Okay. So that's the first experiment.
Another saying this is all we're doing
is we're taking
discrete data points which is what 365
diary entries is doing and then combine
them into one complete story. All
right. Here's another uh experiment you
can do. memory. So, organize 100
classmates and go to a park together and
spend the whole day in a park and
organize the day so that everyone's
doing the same thing. All right?
Everyone's doing the same thing. And
then next day, ask all 100 students to
write down his experience all that one
day. And I guarantee you every person
will be the will be different. Each
person's experience will be unique onto
himself. thus confirming affirming what
Kant said. Okay, the imagination is the
animating force of the universe. Right?
So let's do one more experiment and this
is a thought experiment. This something
you can't do but let's just imagine it.
Imagine you end up on
a island. Okay? And this island is very
fertile, very opulent, lots of fruits,
lots of fish. You don't have to worry
about starving. But one day you go to
sleep and then your mind is wiped clean.
It becomes a tabular
rasa as proposed
by John Lock. Okay. So you're you have
no more memory. You can't speak. You've
lost the capacity of language. You've
lost capacity to reason. You don't know
where you are. You don't know who you
are. Okay. You get up and now the
question then is what will happen to
you? Well, if you're John Lock, what's
going to happen to you is you're going
to starve to death because you don't
know what to eat. Okay? You take a stone
and you put it in your mouth. You take a
leaf, you put in your mouth. You don't
know what to eat. You've lost all um
knowledge. Okay? But according to Kant
what Kant would say is okay sure you've
lost all knowledge but because you have
a priority synthetic knowledge because
you manipulate reality around you
because your mind is very good at
filtering information categories
information it'll take you a very short
amount of time to figure out what is
edible.
Okay, you know stones, wood, that's a
category of stuff you cannot eat. But
then you know fruits, water, fish is
another category of things you can eat.
All right. So and I think just just
through pure
intuition we can figure out you know
what Kant makes more intuitive sense
than John Lock. Okay. So does that make
sense? So again uh first experiment you
can do um and you will
discover like if you do one long entry
it will not correlate to these these
separate entries. Okay. Um the memory
experiment you can also do you can also
do the thought experiment you can't
really do but you can reason it out and
discover it uh to be true. All right. So
that is Kant a very short simple
introduction to Kant. Any questions
before I move on to Hegel?
Yeah, a couple of combined questions.
So, doing this critique of pure
reason as a natural philosopher in maybe
a way Newton might have like did he
think he was doing science? Yeah, that's
a great question. I may just follow up
quickly. Um, do do you do you know
anything about K's current reputation in
scientific community do scientists going
back to okay so two great questions okay
the first question is how did Kant
perceive himself the second great uh
question is how is science uh how does
science perceive him today so um simple
answer is Kant saw himself as a
revolutionary thinker he saw himself as
capernicus he's going to fundamentally
change the way that we perceive the
universe in fact he calls it what his
critical pure reason a cop capernac
revolution. I I'll discuss this later
on. Okay. Uh how how Khan actually
perceived himself. Second is Kant's
ideas. I'll show you later on is really
the basis for modern for modern day
science. Einstein was heavily influenced
by Kant. Einstein read Kant when he was
16 and because of of Kant's theories of
spaceime and through a synthetic
knowledge that gives him the theory of
relativity. Okay. And if you study
quantum mechanics um you will discover a
lot of ideas were heavily influenced by
Kant. So his influence on science is
just incredible. It's it's and um and I
but I'll discuss this moving on. Okay.
All right. Good. So now let's move on to
Hegel. All right. So with Kant his
philosophy is remember
we interact with the
nana which gives us the phenomena the
things that we can see the appearance
there are three major issues that are
unresolved in Kant Kant acknowledges
these issues and it doesn't really
provide a solution okay these three
issues are this the first issue of
course is what is the nomen? What are
the things in themselves? And Khan says
we can never know. Okay, that's the
first major issue. Second issue is
okay, sorry, but if our brains are
capable of reason through uh a synthetic
knowledge, where does knowledge come
from? What's the source for our
mind? Right? And the third problem is
uniformity. If it is true that we are in
fact always uh
projecting onto
um nana to create phenomenon. How do we
know that we're
all doing it the same way? How do we
know that that culturally all cultures
are doing the same way? Are you saying
that the Egyptians, the Chinese, the
Greeks, they all perceive the world in
the same way? Okay. So these are the
three major unresolved issues in Kant.
Nomina. Okay. What is it? And K says we
can never know, right? Because we cannot
imagine ourselves outside of space and
time. What is the source for our minds?
And K says we don't know. It's it's just
there. And the third is uniformity. How
do we know what we see is consistent
with each other? And Khan says we don't
know but we have to believe it. Okay,
otherwise the world doesn't make any
sense. How is it possible uh that
without uniformity you can have
mathematics and science? Okay, but it
doesn't re but again the problem with
Kant is this is not satisfying right? So
Hegel is going to come along and he's
and he's going to provide a theory of
everything. He's going to resolve these
three issues for Kant and create an
entire system of thought that
encompasses everything. Okay. So, so
let's now move on to Hegel. So, Hegel's
major
um insight is what if as we're
perceiving the nana, the nman is
projecting back onto us. So it becomes a
source for our ability to
perceive the nomina. Okay. The so in
other words the nina is really the
source which creates the uniformity. All
right. And so what is this nomina? And
the word that heel uses is
gist. The gist. Okay. And this is a
German word that we translate into mind
or spirit. Okay. So Hegel's major work
is called the themmonology of the mind
which can also be translated into the
theology of the spirit. Okay. So
translators argue about um what the
translation is. The problem is mind and
spirit don't really explain that much.
Okay. So um imagine guys as and this is
a bad metaphor. Okay. But imagine guys
as the internet and we are individual
computers. We're always interacting with
this internet. Okay. So that's that
would give you a basic framework to
understand what GI is. It is a uh
collective consciousness almost. But
that that's not accurate. Okay. To to
fully understand what Gist is, we need
to go into the ethmology of the word.
What words um were influenced uh in
English by Gist. And there are three
words that were influenced by Gist.
Okay. The first word is ghost.
So ghost is the idea that the gist is
coexisting with us, right? The guy the g
is not separate from us. It is it is
coexisting with us. It's here and now.
All right. Second word is
uh
geyser. Geyser and expansion a spawning
up. Okay. So the gist is always growing.
It wants to grow and expand. The third
uh English word that comes from guys is
gist. the gist of an argument, the
essence of an argument. So what Hegel is
saying is the gist is the essence of
reality. The gist comes first. It's the
source for who we
are.
Okay. So again to understand guys think
of it as an internet but the internet
that is coexisting with us that is
always expanding forward and which is
the essence of all life itself. That's
why we say that um Hegel is an idealist
right he he doesn't care about the
material world he doesn't think it
really matters what matters to him is
the gist itself the ideas because that's
what drives human history. All
right. Okay. So, let's talk about how he
perceives the geyser. How does the guys
actually move? And for him, what matters
are not the things. What matters is not
the ideas. What matters is the movement
of things. And so for Hegel, uh the the
main thing that moves is the dialectic.
Okay? And and this is famous because
obviously from the dialectic we have the
thesis which moves to the
antithesis which moves into the
symphysis and this is the movement of
human history. Okay. And the way to
understand this is we all seek
self-nowledge. But the way to seek
self-nowledge is by asking who we are
not which creates the antithesis and
then we have when when we have the idea
of who we are not this comes in conflict
with who we are which then creates new
knowledge. Okay. All right. So in order
to understand this idea let's do a
thought experiment.
Hey, the thought come is this. Okay,
let's go back to the island and there's
a there's 100 of us, okay? And we all
sleep in different corners of the
island. And again, during the night when
we sleep, our minds are wiped clean.
We're all now tableasa. We have no more
memory, okay? We wake up and we forget
that there's other people there. We
don't even know who we are. When we wake
up, what we see is the universe, the
space and time. And we think that we are
the universe, that we are space and
time, and there is a reconciliation
between us and the world, okay? And
we're really happy. But as we move move
along on the beach, we see someone else.
And this other person threatens us
because it's like us, but it's not like
us. And now this person has destroyed my
conception of the universe which is like
I am the universe or I am God. And this
creates conflict. Okay. We fight. We
might actually physically fight. We
might argue. Okay. But over time we
create a symphysis which is like okay
the two of us are now the universe.
Problem is we walk along and we meet
another person another person. Okay. So
this is a constant process. But over
time, um, even though there's conflict,
even though there's violence, it's all a
natural part of enlightenment. It's all
part of the process of reconciliation
where eventually all 100 of us, we
rediscover who we are through um
conflict and differentiation and we form
a collective consciousness. We become
what con what Hegel says is the absolute
spirit.
Okay. Absolute spirit and that is the
progress and the purpose of our lives.
All right. So let me frame it in a
different way. All right. So what what
um Hegel is saying. Okay. And again this
these are not his words. These are my
words. So be careful. Okay. But I think
this is the best way to explain what
he's really saying about the movement of
history. God has two forms. God is the
gist. Okay. But God is
also the
universe. Does that make sense? Okay.
So why would God do this? Why would God
be both the universe and be the guys?
Because because God is trying to create
reconciliation between itself and all
the things in the universe. It's trying
to come to peace, a reconciliation, an
awareness between itself and us. Okay.
So the gist through the dialect it is
growing and growing until it becomes the
universe itself and that is the end of
history. All right and this is what we
call a
teological movement of history where
things are moving towards their purpose.
So what Hegel says is the world is
becoming.
Okay. Do not think of the world as being
but becoming as constantly in a process
of transformation of growth of
expansion. Why? Because it wants to
become being. The being is when we are
completely reconciled to
God. All right? That's the end of the
world. That's the end of history. the
the reconciliation between us and God.
When we when we become when we we become
God and but God become us, then there's
no more differentiation. There's now no
more conflict. We are moving
towards this because the world is
theological. Every single thing that we
do is moving
towards the one reunion with God. Okay.
Um the guys, so so to prove this, Hegel
discusses the guys. How do we know the
guys? Well, in culture, we know the guys
through um sorry, art,
philosophy, and religion. And when you
study these three things historically,
what you will discover is they've
they're all
progressing. Okay. So, so in terms of
art right now, you are we are in the
romantic period, which is the highest
period of art because it is synthesizing
all previous periods of art. uh religion
the highest the highest religion is
Christianity because it is the beginning
of a reconciliation between us and God.
Jesus was the great democratic force
that allow us to now all in our own way
access God before God was captured and
imprisoned by the priest and Jesus freed
God from the priest and now and so
Christianity is the highest religion and
of course
philosophy what's the highest philosophy
he go right because this theory of the
gist is the end point of all our
knowledge from the gist we can now
finally reconcile our we can move toward
towards reconciliation. Okay. And so
from um this there are some major
influences. Okay. So let's talk about
the three major influences legacies of
Hegel. By far the most influential of
course is the creation of Marxism.
Because what K Marx will do is he will
take this theory of Hegel uh the
movement of history the dialectic and he
will create something called dialect
materialism. He will invert Hegel
because Hegel says it's only ideas that
matter. And what Marx will say is that
nope only material things matter. Okay.
He will invert um Hegel but he he will
also adopt a lot of Hegelian thinking.
Okay. So um the dialectic becomes a very
important part of Marxist um theology
sorry ideology which we'll study next
class. Okay. So that's the first major
influence. Second major influence is
um in the idea of God is dead.
Okay. So it was not Nichi actually who
introduced this term. It was Hegel. And
by God is dead. What Hegel is saying is
we need to change our conception of God.
Okay. Before we thought God was aloof,
distant and absolute. And now I'm
presenting you a
more advanced version of God which is a
God that is moving in us towards
itself. Okay. So God is that and of
course the third major influence which
we will discuss later on is the idea of
the nation
state because this theory of gist
becomes um part of the nation state and
so now because of Hegel we could believe
that the nation state can have a soul.
Okay. And this will lead to a lot of
problems which include imperialism war
and other really fun things. Okay. But
we cannot understate the influence of
Hegel. All right. So um that's Hegel.
All right. So um any any questions
before I move on to the legacy of Kant
and Hegel?
Was this clear? This was this clear?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Good. Good. Good. The
the contrast is really interesting
because like both both these
philosophers make great intellectuals,
right? And one thing I can picture
living within right and being very
comfortable
saying something concrete about the
world. Yeah. And
I'm not sure about Hegel. Do you think
he How much do you think he really
believed what he was talking about as
opposed to like this is a very elegant
explanation of the world, right? It
seems it seems a little
bit They're both abstract but but Hegel
seems more abstract
by almost scale. Yeah. So um that's a
great point. Yeah. I mean how I mean
like I mean Kant is very logical Hegel
is very abstract. Um so if you read the
critic of pure reason um if you spend
enough time on it you will get through
it. Okay you will be able to master it.
Whereas if you try to read Hegel,
especially the phenology of spirit, it's
it's just impossible. Uh it's like
everyone who reads it will have like a
different interpretation. Uh and the
reason why is what Hegel is trying to
do, he's trying to synthesize all human
knowledge. Okay? He's trying to take
everything that's happened, everything
that we know, and he's trying to
synthesize it into a system, which Khan
just basically said we can't really do.
Okay. Um, so I mean I'm not an expert on
Hegel. Um, and I don't want to be an
expert on Hegel actually because I think
I will go crazy if I read too much
Hegel. Um, so so but but but I I do know
there's a lot of controversy around
Hegel. He's he's actually gaining um
he's actually regaining popularity in in
our in our age because of the idea of
the gist, right? Because we live in a
two materialistic world. But um but yeah
um sorry if I'm yeah rambling on. Okay.
All right. Let's move on to the legacy
because the legacy will give us further
insight into
uh Khan and Hegel as well
as help us better understand the world.
Okay. So Emanuel Kant. So remember like
Emanuel Kant for him he was really aware
of what it was doing and his argument
was that the critical pure reason it
marks a radical new stage in human
history. It is like capernicus. Remember
capernicus his major contribution was
before we thought we were at the center
of the universe right and
then capernicus banish us to the margins
of the universe. So it's a new way of
perceiving the world and so trying to do
the same thing. Okay. So precaut the
philosophers thought we we that there
was an objective reality and that we
were just observers of this objective
reality. But through logic and
experience we could ultimately access
this objective reality. And Khan says no
no no the world is entirely subjective.
We project our imagination our ideas
onto the universe. We are active
participants in the world. Um and this
will give rise to idea of romanticism.
Okay. Uh which is that the human
imagination is the highest ideal. it is
in in many ways um partake it
participates in god itself right so that
is Kant's major revolution uh this is
fed Hegel and let's look really let's
remind ourselves the difference between
Kant and Hegel so what Kant would say is
there are limits to reason okay we can
never know the mind of God and where
what Hegel says is no the mind of God is
a dialectic okay and therefore we can
know the mind of God All right. Um, Kot
will say the world is what we will it to
be meaning we have free
will. And then uh Hegel will say we are
moving towards the end of history which
we are progressing but this means we
have no free will. Okay. Everything has
been planned from the beginning. All
these conflicts are part of a process of
eventual enlightenment. And K will say
we must believe in God for morality to
exist. This is really important point.
So Khan is extremely logical. is very
honest and he and he says there's no
nothing I can do to prove God exists but
we must believe God to exist otherwise
we have no morality in this world okay
he also says we must believe free will
exists even though there's no there's no
logical proof of free will otherwise
what's the point of existence okay um
Hegel says uh God is dead I've created a
new god and is a theological god that is
forcing us towards there. All right. So
these are the three major differences
between Kant and Hegel. All right. So
now let's look at the legacy of Kant.
Okay. So what's amazing is the more
science progresses, the more Kant is
proving right. So neuroscience is
telling us today that we hallucinate the
reality. All right? And there are lots
of experiments that prove this. So let's
go over some really quick uh uh
examples. We see a triangle, right?
Guess what, guys? It doesn't exist.
Okay, it's just part part of our
imagination. These lines exist. The
triangle doesn't exist. But the first
thing we see is this triangle that does
not exist. All
right. Um, this thing moves. Okay. But
we know um it doesn't really move. Okay.
So, so our mind is playing tricks tricks
on us. We see this as slanted. Okay.
When we actually um take them side by
side together, you'll see them as
parallel. Another mind trick that's
being
played. Which is bigger? Well, they're
the same, but because
of these circles, we think this is
bigger than that. Okay, another mind
trick that's playing that's being played
on us. Um, A and B are different colors,
right? They see it's obvious they're
different colors, right? But actually,
they're the same color. Okay, another
mind trick that's being played. So um
neuroscientists have done a lot of
experiments and they've proven to to us
that we constantly participate in
reality. We hallucinate reality which is
what Kant originally
proposed. All right, let's move on to
artificial intelligence. Okay,
artificial intelligence shows us the
limits of the blank slate theory. Okay,
so let's imagine you actually had a
blank slate in your minds. Well, that
would be very that would be extremely
problematic and we know because of how
artificial intelligence works. All
right, let's look at um supervised
learning. So when we talk about
artificial intelligence, it doesn't
actually exist. What exists is the idea
of supervised learning. And the idea is
this. We're trying to teach a machine,
an algorithm to recognize a picture.
Okay? So what we do is this. We feed a
lot of training data to into the
algorithm. And we're talking like
millions and millions of pictures. And
then we label this data so that the
machine is able to using um um its own
analysis figure out the differences.
Okay, it basically turns every picture
into a mathematical concept and then if
you if you if you um train it well
enough then it's able to differentiate
between a triangle and a circle. Okay,
that's the idea of machine learning.
Okay, same concept here. Okay, you have
to feed it millions millions of pictures
and you have to label these different
pictures and then the machine will
mathematically be able to figure out
which is which. Okay, how the machine
does that we don't we're not really
concerned about but we're but we need to
train the machine and the problem with
this is it's a very expensive it's very
timeconuming. All right, now let's
compare this with how a human does it
right? at a human. If I just give you a
picture of a sheep, you're able to know
what a sheep is. And why does that
happen? Okay, so um a machine is able to
tell you this is sheep. Okay, but what a
machine is not able to tell you is is
this sheep real or fake,
right? Is it is this a real or fake
sheep?
Well, we think it's fake, right? But
what the machine says it we don't know.
And the machine is correct. Real fake
are categories of a mind. Right? What
how do we know this is a fake sheep and
not a real sheep? Do you understand? So
machine is saying you know if I don't
know anything if I have no apore
synthetic knowledge then I cannot
differentiate between fake and real. But
a child anyone can can know this is a
fake sheep sheep because obviously we
have categories in our minds.
Okay. A machine could not tell you what
this is. Why? Because this has become a
schema, a a concept. But any child can
tell you this is a sheep. Okay. And
again, uh so this is artificial
intelligence is showing us that Kant was
correct. All right. As I mentioned, Kant
inspired Einstein to dream up the theory
of relativity. All right. So um so
Einstein read Kant when he was 16. It
had a huge influence on Einstein.
um spacetime curvature is influenced by
it but also the theory of relativity.
Okay. And the theory of relativity it's
it's fairly
straightforward. Let's just say that I'm
sitting on a platform a train platform
and you are and and and you guys are
across from me. Okay. Now we're not
moving right and we know we're not
moving but let's just say that for
whatever reason
simultaneously both platforms are moving
at the same speed. Okay. from our
perspective we're still not moving and
that's the idea of relativity where the
laws of physics are relative to where we
are at the moment okay and this again is
influenced by con what's really fun is
to think about quantum mechanics okay so
quantum mechanics confirms things in
themselves nominal are not knowable to
us so this is a major argument between
Kant and Hegel okay and so
um quantum
mechanics so we looked at light and we
want to know what the essence of light
is. What are photons? And um we discover
something really problematic which is we
discover that photons are both wavelike
and particle-like. They're both wave
movement and particle something static.
And what's even more problematic is what
we discovered is you're not able to
figure out the state of the light if
it's a wave or a particle until you
actually measure it. So in other words
before you
measure light before you me measure
particles they are simultaneously
occupying many different possibilities
something we call a superp position.
Okay and this this idea of wave function
a wave function is all the probabilities
of of its position in space. When you
measure it it collapses into one data
point. Okay does that make sense?
All right. So, um, you know, in school
we teach you the bore model of the atom,
but in really it's an cloud, meaning we
don't know where the electrons are at a
certain state. We can only know the
probability of where it could be. Okay.
And so, that's a problem here. All
right. So, this idea of quantum
mechanics, Einstein hated this theory.
He thought this was disgusting. There's
too much random randomness. It's ugly.
Um, he hated it. Okay. He he thought
that God as an architect had an elegant
mind and we come with these theories
like quantum mechanics which actually
makes absolutely no sense you're
insulting God. So to
disprove quantum mechanics Einstein
wrote a paper on something called
quantum entanglement. The idea is this
okay things cannot be measured. Oh sorry
things we we cannot know the state of
things of atoms until they are measured.
Right? Well, in quantum mechanics, um,
things also exist in opposition towards
each other. Okay? So, so these two, so
maybe two atoms are aligned together and
their two states are mirror images of
each other. So, what you can do is this.
If you split these two and you send them
off in different corners of the
universe, according to quantum
mechanics, the moment you measure the
first atom, the second atom must also
reveal itself even though you have not
measured it. and and also has to be
simultaneous even though these two atoms
could possibly at at different ends of
the universe. Okay, quantum entanglement
and Einstein says this can't possibly be
true. This is a stupid idea and this
proves quantum mechanics doesn't work.
The problem is this. The problem is
we've done experiments to prove quant
quantum entanglement actually does work
and this is true. Okay, not only that,
but quantum mechanics has proven itself
to be the most successful theory in
physics of all time because it's given
rise to the transistor. Okay, the idea
of the transistor is if you can
understand electrons then you can
manipulate electrons in a way that
allows you to manipulate it which allows
you to make calculations on it. Okay. So
the transition has given rise to the
computer which has given rise to the
internet. Okay, basically create the
world that we live in today. So about
quantum mechanics, we cannot have um the
world we live in today. Okay. So um but
again even though we know quantum
mechanics to be true, we don't know why
it's true. Okay. There are lots of
mysteries in quantum mechanics. One of
the biggest problems in quantum
mechanics is something called Shainger's
cat. So Shaner created a thought
experiment to show you how problematic
quantum mechanics is. Let's just say
that you have a cat inside a box and
there's radioactive material inside this
box. Okay? And you don't know, you can
never know if this cat is dead or alive.
So, um the only thing you can say is it
is both dead and alive, which is which
again is problematic, but it's that
that's not it. It's even more
problematic because another physicist
Wner said, "Okay, let's do another
thought experiment. Let's just say,
okay, I'm a scientist. I open the box.
Then I know the state of the cat now,
right? I didn't know it before. Once I
open the box, I can see the cat is alive
or dead. Now I know. But let's just say
that there's a friend in my laboratory
who is observing me, okay? And he
doesn't he has not himself open the box.
So when I open the box and I find the
cat is dead, what happens to him?
Okay. Well, there are different
possibilities. The first possibility is
um he now knows. Okay. So reality has
changed for him once he has this
information. The other possibility
is he doesn't know but he thinks he
knows. Okay. So this shows you how
problematic um quantum mechanics is. And
you can keep on going like this to the
nth degree. Okay. In other words, the
question that they're trying to deal
with, the question that quantum
mechanics doesn't really isn't really
able to resolve is, is reality
subjective or objective? Can there be a
one reality in which we all live in or
is reality constantly multiplying
subjectively? Okay. In other words,
whenever we make a decision when
whenever we um make whenever we act, it
changes reality for us but not for for
not but not for others. Okay, is it
possible like we all live within our own
universe that is unique to us? Okay,
that's a question quantum mechanics
cannot answer and it creates a huge
problem in quantum mechanics. But if we
go back to Kant, well, the answer's
obvious. It is true that we do create
our own individual reality, right? The
nomen is something we can never see.
This is quantum mechanics. The mind when
it interfaces with um the thing itself,
it creates the world that we live in.
Okay. So this brings back to the point
that the imagination is the animating
force of the universe. When we use the
imagination, we create our own reality
that is distinct from other
realities. Okay? So does that make
sense? Okay. So um okay
um another way of framing this is what
what is happening here is K describing
the world we live in or did he create
this reality that we live in? Okay. and
and and and so this another saying this
saying this that then is rather than
artificial intelligence, neuroscience,
quantum mechanics um all confirming what
Kant first argued. Another say of saying
this is Kant gave them the intellectual
capacity come up with these theories by
themselves. Okay. Another thing of
saying this is this philosophy creates
the boundaries of the human
imagination and science all science is
doing is playing with these boundaries
to confirm what is known within these
boundaries. Okay, that's that's that's
the radical statement that I want you I
want you to think about. Okay, is
science capable of come up with new
ideas by itself? And the argument I
would make is no because you can have
data. What matters is your
interpretation of this data. And this
interpretation of data comes from the
gist. Okay. The the collective mind that
philosophers like Kant and Hegel
created. And this is problematic because
we live in a world today that is
undervaluing philosophy and arts and
overvaluing STEM, engineering,
technology.
Okay. And so what my my my argument to
you is if that is the case, if we just
spend all our money on science, it's all
going to be
useless. Okay? Because in the Dante
world, Dante talks to God, writes the
divine comedy. Divine comedy then
inspires Khan to write the critique of
pure reason, which inspires Hegel. And
then two and the two together will go
inspire neuroscience, artificial
intelligence and uh quantum mechanics.
Okay. So in other words, it is
imagination that creates all reality,
not just our individual reality. There
are some of us who are geniuses who are
able
to imagine a new reality in which we can
now inhabit and participate in. Right?
Um and evidence for this is you
know ever
since the Germans uh so so Kant also um
conceptualized the United Nations. Okay.
Um ever since Connisburg fell ever since
the Germans lost World War
II we have not made major advances in
science. Okay, remember the transisure
is not a major advance. It's just techn
it's just a it's just technology. It's
it's just taking a science and then um
expressing it uh uh in in in the world
that we live in today. Okay. So without
culture, without the gist, is it
possible to contribute uh to advanced
science? Okay. And I think the answer is
no. I think we're stuck where we are
because we've abandoned culture. We've
abandoned gist. The gist. So um Emanuel
Kant was a citizen of Connisburg. In
fact he was called the Connisburg clock.
Why? Because he was so
regimented. He took he made sure at a
very specific time he he could he would
take a walk somewhere. Okay. And so so
by observing where he was at a certain
time the residents of Connorsburg would
know what time it is. All right. So um
you can make the argument that that Kant
um created Connisburg because Connisburg
would after Kant become the in
intellectual scientific center of Europe
but Kinsburg also created him. Okay,
which is very uh an idea which would be
very familiar to Hegel. All right. So
that is it for Kant. We now we will now
move on to Marx and Freud. Okay. Um but
was this clear? Any any
questions? Okay, great. So, uh next
class we will do um marks